un referendo convocado por la cdau pero
aplazado varias veces el primer paso
hacia la vuelta al orden constitucional
con elecciones previstas para febrero de
2024 la nueva constitución de Mali
propone una profunda revisión de sus
instituciones con la creación de un
senador un tribunal de cuentas y
gobiernos regionales descentralizados 13
de las lenguas nacionales de Mali
pasarían a ser oficiales Mientras que el
francés quedaría reducido a lengua de
trabajo pero este texto reforzaría los
poderes del jefe del Estado el
presidente nombraría al Primer Ministro
y a los ministros Por tanto determinaría
la política nacional y podría presentar
el mismo proyectos legislativos la nueva
constitución también consolidaría el
carácter laico del Estado maliense a
ellos se han opuesto una veintena de
organizaciones islámicas estas primeras
elecciones desde 2020 y el golpe de
estado del Coronel asimismoita prometen
ser todo un desafío por ejemplo no se
podrá votar en kidala Región del Norte
dominada por antiguos Rebeldes
independentistas Opuestos al